herzlich willkommen bei die richtigen
fragen hier live aus berlin
bitte bleiben sie zu hause so hat es die
kanzlerin gestern in einem dramatischen
video-statement formuliert wie
dramatisch wird diese kroner lage für
uns und wie groß wird das chaos
[Musik]
darüber möchte sprechen mit meinen
gästen bundesverkehrsminister andreas
scheuer teil des corona kabinetts ich
möchte sprechen mit gabriel felbermayr
dem aus vom institut für weltwirtschaft
und karl lauterbach dem
spd-gesundheitsexperte uns zugeschaltet
sind marie christine ostermann
unternehmerin und wolfgang kubicki jetzt
haben wir sie auch im bild der
bundestags-vizepräsident und
stellvertretender vorsitzender der fdp
schön dass sie alle da sind eher scheuer
sie sind am nächsten dran kann man sagen
hier in dieser runde an der kanzlerin
auch teil des corona kabinetts erklären
sie uns mal was war das gestern ja das
hat sich über die letzten tage schon
entwickelt weil wir einfach auch die
situation der zahlen gesehen habe der
neuinfektionen und die kanzlerin war
sehr konzentriert und auch um getrieben
von diesen
neuen fällen jetzt hatten wir natürlich
hoffnung dass die ausbreitung gestoppt
ist sind wir durch den ganzen sommer
gegangen und jetzt sind machen sie dazu
naiv nein überhaupt nicht wir waren
immer konzentriert immer sehr sehr
klaren der lage dran aber jetzt war es
notwendig auch zu aufzuzeigen wir
brauchen jetzt den stopp der ausbreitung
wir brauchen jetzt die konzentration wir
brauchen jetzt die vernunft um dann für
beispielsweise die weihnachtszeit oder
die weiteren monate einfach eine
einsendungen hinzubekommen wenn man sich
die europakarte anschaut dann haben wir
die ausbreitung des virus am besten
gemanagt als deutsche trotzdem die
sprunghaft angestiegenen zahlen haben
natürlich dazu auch die er den appell
notwendig gemacht als ich mir das video
steht man der kanzlerin angeschaut habe
da hatte ich so ein déjà vu und dachte
ich bin eigentlich wieder im frühjahr
wenn die kanzlerin jetzt sagt ich bin
soll zu hause bleiben dann ist das doch
nichts anderes als wir schon erlebt
haben oder aber das können wir uns alle
ja nicht aussuchen und die kanzlerin
sucht sich es nicht also ist es so die
phase wie im frühjahr nein wir haben
sicherlich nicht die phase wie ganz zu
haben fangen also stichwort lockdown
aber wir müssen jetzt den stopp
hinbekommen weil dann wird es in den
folge monaten schlimmer oder ähnlich wie
in der ersten phase und das wollen wir
ja nicht und deswegen wir wollen nicht
dass das gesundheitssystem überfordert
werden wir wollen nicht dass die
wirtschaft wieder eine lockdown erlebt
wir wollen nicht dass eine ausbreitung
stattfindet wir wollen nicht dass alte
menschen zu hause bleiben müssen
schülerinnen und schüler zu hause
bleiben müssen und deswegen brauchen wir
jetzt die volle konzentration auf den
stop kubicki wo waren sie gestern als
die kanzlerin das berühmte
video-statement vorgelesen hat oder sich
an die nation gewandt hat muss man ja
schon sagen und wie haben sie das wahr
genommen war das sinnvoll oder ist das
panikmache
zunächst aber war ich auch dem wasser
haben meinen wir gut in die werft
gebracht ins winterlager und haben es
damit heute noch zusammengesessen und er
wissen dass getrunken mit liebe bush auf
der kanzler nicht erreicht es gibt keine
verpflichtung sich videobotschaft der
kanzler anzuschauen weil wenn minister
scheuer davon redet wir wollen nicht
wieder dass menschen zu hause bleiben
dass die eigenen
in ihrem pflegeheim bleiben müssen dass
kinder nicht zur schule gehen können
dann ist der appell der kanzlerin nichts
anderes als an verzweiflungstaten sofort
die menschen hier zu einem freiwilligen
doch dort auf das heißt nicht mehr zu
reichen nicht mehr zusammen zu kommen zu
hause zu bleiben und er sagt ja
verzweifelt um ich glaube schon dass wir
uns lösen müssen von diesen dauert
fallzahlen weil sie zwar wichtig sind
weil ich alleine aussagekräftig sind
wichtig ist die frage wie dies in
unserer intensivbetten aus mit
behandlungsmöglichkeiten und wie
sinnvoll eine gefährdung des
gesundheitssystems meilenweit entfernt
das droht nicht weh dann früher noch
jetzt droht das ist ein ganzes
überlastet wird insofern sollten wir uns
konzentrieren auch die maßnahmen die
wirklich sinnvoll sind und nicht die
bevölkerung in angst und schrecken
versetzt und kubicki bevor wir weiter
sprechen wir wollen uns noch einmal
genau anschauen was die kanzlerin
gestern gesagt hat wir haben der
ausschnitte aus ihrer rede vorbereitet
die die kanzlerin in einem video
statement gestern aufgezeichnet hat und
wollen uns diese einmal anschauen
genau das ist heute mein appell an sie
treffen sie sich mit deutlich weniger
menschen ob außerhalb oder zu hause
ich bitte sie verzichten sie auf jede
reise die nicht wirklich zwingend
notwendig ist
auf jede feier die nicht wirklich
zwingend notwendig ist
bitte bleiben sie wenn immer möglich zu
hause an ihrem wohnort herr kubicki
werden sie zu hause bleiben richten sie
sich nach den worten der kanzlerin nein
ich kann es schon nicht weil ich als
abgeordneter des deutschen bundestags
sitzungswoche wieder teilen wird auch
musste ich werde von strande nach berlin
vereinen ich kann nur noch mal dringend
davor warnen diese warnungen der
kanzlerin nicht mehr auszustoßen 20 auch
zu stark zu gewichten wir haben momentan
keine erkenntnisse darüber dass
touristische reisen im inland
infektionsgeschehen massiv beigetragen
haben auch die restaurants um geister im
sucher anders nicht was ist fast vorüber
sind
heißt das die bürger sollen sich nicht
daran halten was die tanzender gesagt
hat die bürger sollen das tun was sie
für richtig halten sie sind dazu nicht
viel am sonntag zunächst antwort ich
aber die bundeskanzlerin nicht ist nicht
diejenigen die einfach anordnen kann
das verhalten sollen jeder er das gefühl
hat müssen diesen worten folgen soll das
tun weil jeder das gefühl hatte er kann
auch anders weiterleben sollte dies auch
tue und noch einmal sein akt der
verzweifelung und ich verstehe nicht
warum wir uns nicht auf die ihnen dinge
konzentrieren die wirklich desinfektions
verschiedene kontrolle bringen warum ich
wirklich hochzeit feiern geburtstags
verkehren noch alles vor allem in berlin
gefunden werden wo er mehrere
persönlichkeiten haben die sich hier
küssen und anfassen wenn alle bachelor-
und dass wir uns nicht auf die senioren
pflegeeinrichtung konzentrieren wenn
herr sparen seiner aufgabe gerecht würde
und diese heimweg es ist kein wasser
ausstatten würde sowohl für die bewohner
wie auch für die pflegekräfte und die
sonstige bediensteten hätten wir
deutlich geringere probleme denn das ist
die gruppe der besonders intensiv
betroffen ist von der chora pandemie ist
das denn für sie schon eine art lockdown
von dem die kanzlerin da spricht naja
doktorand wäre es wenn es behördliche
anordnung gebe aber es der aufruf zu
einem freiwilligen doktor und noch
einmal menschen die das gefühl haben sie
daran halten sollten das tun menschen
die sorge und angst haben sollten sich
zu verhalten die kanzlerin das anbietet
und die anderen menschen sollten ihren
beruf nachgehen die sollen ihre kinder
in die schule schicken sie sollten wenn
es geht zwar nicht mit hunderten von
leuten gemeinsam feiern aber im
restaurant trotzdem wieder erstens muss
ich nehmen denn noch einmal die hotels
und die restaurants mit die gaststätten
haben einige konzept entwickelt das auch
erfolgreich gewesen ist jetzt mit diesem
privaten lok tor um tor zu bestrafen
weil die ich für absolut unpassend
herr lauterbach herr kubicki nennt das
freiwilliger lockdown ist das so nein es
kann frage doch dann habe ich will
zunächst einmal ein paar dinge
korrigieren und der merkel recht geben
also wir müssen tatsächlich angela
merkel hat ja quasi dazu aufgerufen dass
wir jetzt die kontakte massiv reduzieren
also um 30 oder 50 prozent dass wir viel
weniger kontakte haben und das ist
epidemiologisch nicht geboten denn wenn
wir das nicht machen
noch zwei drei wochen durchhalten und
dann werden wir tatsächlich ein charter
und bekommen zunächst in den städten und
wenn das dann noch immer nicht in den
griff
aber wenn die katze und jetzt sagt bitte
bleiben sie zu hause dann ist das doch
nichts anderes als ein schatten
lassen sie es nennen wie sie auch immer
wollen aber die die nerven ruft dazu auf
dass wir quasi uns selbst weil in
kontakten so stark zurücknehmen wie die
reifen sind nicht das einzige problem
sondern einfach schlichten und actelion
mittlerweile eine so dynamische
entwicklung der fälle und das ist
wichtig dass jeder seine zuschauer auf
papier an der zahl an er wert von
ungefähr 1.3 1.4 wenn man den jetzt noch
mal so durch laufen ließe wie ihr jetzt
stattfindet also wir würden jetzt sagen
wir so weiter leben im großen ganzen wie
es verwehrt bliebe 1,3 ungefähr wir
jetzt
dann würden bis also bis weihnachten
würden zusätzlich zu den todesfällen die
wir haben auf der grundlage der
berechnungen ich habe selbst auch
berechnung gemacht zusätzliche 50.000
menschen verstorben sein
bislang aber hat aber die deutschen ihr
leben jetzt seit monaten immer wieder
neue horrorzahlen die von verschiedenen
politikern virologen epidemiologen dort
auf den tisch kommt haben sie das gefühl
haben wir das haben sie das gefühl dass
man die deutschen damit noch erreicht
ich gesagt
stellen sie die zahl infrage oder was
ist die fahrweise worauf ich stehe ich
stelle nicht ihre hochrechnungen frage
ich sage nur dass sozusagen die
deutschen richten sich sich in den
vergangenen monaten von vielen
politikern und 100 und experten immer
wieder gehört haben was passieren kann
es ist dann nicht passiert also bis
jetzt zumindest das ist auch nicht
richtig
also die im großen und ganzen ist es
also ungefähr so gekommen wie wir vorher
gesagt haben ich hatte zum beispiel vor
zwei monaten hatte ich aus der gruppe
gibt sie wurden lassen also wenn ich
jetzt nach jedem satz unterbrochen
herr kubicki kann sich über lange
strecken gut konzentrieren ich bin schon
leichter wenn ich das jetzt sozusagen
hintereinander sagen da gerade wenn sie
auch sagen wir um dinge geht die mir
persönlich wichtig zu sagen also saison
stimmt es nicht dass wir ständig falsche
prognosen abgegeben haben die prognosen
sind im großen und ganzen so gekommen
wie gesagt ich hatte zum beispiel ich
glaube sogar in ihrem blatt vor acht
wochen gesagt dass wir wenn wir so
weitermachen in acht wochen wieder 6000
fälle haben das ist genau so gekommen
übrigens keinen sonderwissen soll das
haben auch andere zu verrechnet im
großen und ganzen kann es relativ gut
verwerflichen und hier mit dem r wird
von 1,3 wenn wir das durchlaufen ließen
bis dezember was niemand auch nur für
denkbar halte dann wären selbst dann
also 50.000 menschen sterben bei einer
sterblichkeit von einem prozent die für
ein altes land wie deutschland von den
wissenschaftlern die davon leben von
dieser arbeit arbeit berechnet worden
ist wenn das gesundheitssystem
überlastet wäre werden wir aber
tatsächlich in einer situation kennen wo
das gesundheitssystem dies nicht
beherrschen würden dann gehen wir mit
dem einen prozent nie hin
das heißt wir wurden natürlich das würde
nicht also seine rangeht ethische
überlegungen war das wird natürlich kein
politiker verantworten können das wurde
ein scheuer nicht verantworten wollen
verzögern nicht frau merkel nicht ich
nicht das würde niemand verantworten
können somit wir haben zwei
möglichkeiten das sind eigentlich die
einzigen möglichkeiten entweder wir
kriegen das in den nächsten wochen in
den griff bevor die zahlung richtig hoch
werden oder aber wir müssen wieder zu
staus kommen und das ist die wahrheit
war die dynamik ist ungebrochen und
daher hat merkel mit dem dramatischen
appell vollkommen rechten schaut es für
völlig also was ist los was er kubicki
eben vorgetragen hat dass wir uns also
das wie folgt vor tagen jeder macht was
er will so nach dem motto alten ziehen
sich zurück und die jungen leute also
gehen wieder in die restaurants ja das
ist auch wirklich noch nicht wahrsagen
oder wirklich mein kollege kubicki als
vizepräsident des deutschen bundestages
also ich habe ihn jetzt nicht sitzen
sehen dass er einen alu helm aufhat
das sehe ich jetzt nicht so richtig gut
aber trotzdem lieber kollege kubicki die
ist ja wirklich verantwortung nach hause
wenn sie so eine so einen wortschatz
verwenden auch ihr parteivorsitzender
alle müssen doch zusammenhelfen ihrer
sicht den neuen richtig verrückt
geworden oder wieso sich das würde ich
gerne würde ich beim kollegen kubicki
nie sagen dass er verrückt geworden ist
aber trotzdem jeder hat eine
verantwortung 89 prozent der bürgerinnen
und bürger tolerieren tolerieren und
akzeptieren und unterstützen diesen
harten kurs wir haben nicht von einem
lockdown gesprochen sondern die
kanzlerin hat für einen appell
formuliert einen appell jetzt vernünftig
zu sein nicht mehr und nicht weniger
weil sie nicht nur fachlich umtreibt
sondern ich habe es erlebt emotional um
13 will keinen zweiten lok dann keiner
will einen zweiten lok dann um eben
nicht das gesundheitssystem zu
überfordern
um eben perspektive für die gastronomen
zu geben dem mittelständler zu geben und
so weiter brauchen wir jetzt den stop
damit wir durch die wintermonate kjaer
gehen das ist nichts anderes ist nicht
verantwortungslos sondern sehr gut
abgewogen und kalkuliert herr kubicki
der bundesverkehrsminister vermutet dass
sie da irgendwo an alle hut versteckt
haben verraten sie uns gibt's da ein
armut bei ihnen wie reagieren sie auf
das was hier der verkehrsminister sagt
und auch er lauter war und auch karl
lauterbach reagiere ich wie immer man
halbwegs an von dem was das 8 in den
meisten fällen oder stimmt ja nicht dass
alle seine busse welche hier
eingetroffen sind aber die argumentation
ebene der scheuer gewählter ist genau
das was wir uns in der demokratie gar
nicht leisten dürfe ich finds an die
unverschämtheit neuen maßnahmen der
regierung oder von angela merkel infrage
gestellt so sollten die ecke von carola
gedrängt zu werden von alkohol trägern
also wenn das die e mail software wie
debattieren beweist auch lassen der
steuer unabhängig von dieser geschichte
wie sollst den batterien nach 14 tagen
nach 14 tagen weitere 14 tage weitere 14
tage weil jedes mal wenn das virus noch
da ist das leben wieder exponentiell
frage gestellt werden könnte durch ein
neuer ausbruch serie und das ich höre
von der mode aber von anderen das soll
dann erledigt werden wenn wir an
impfstoff haben du bist wir durchgehend
durch die gesamte bevölkerung vorgehen
als halbjahr das bedeutet die nächsten
zwei drei jahre
sind wir mit den appellen der kanzler
leben zu hause zu bleiben nicht mehr in
restaurants zu gehen obwohl sich alle
darauf eingerichtet haben die gelehrigen
zu beachten bekämpfen wir doch die
hotspots dort wo die ausbruchsgeschehen
sind bei dem großen hochzeitsfeier an
bei den junggesellenabschieden bei den
großen geburtstagsfeier von menschen die
eben auch große familien haben mit genau
da müssen wir ansetzen würde helfen wir
ihnen mit ffb zwei masken die unserer
hilfe bedürfen dann haben wir nicht das
problem dass weder kanzlerin hören
müssen wo ist der herr sparen mit der
richtigen ausrüstung der masken für die
altenpflege ein wort für die
krankenhäuser
herr kubicki vielen vielen dank ich
bevor ich zu ihnen kommen lauterbach ich
gerne einmal herren selber meyer zu wort
kommen lassen vom institut für
weltwirtschaft felbermayr wir haben
jetzt schon direkt in den ersten minuten
waren sich hitzige diskussionen erlebt
was macht das für den eindruck auf sie
und vor allem was bedeuten die worte der
kanzlerin für die wirtschaft es ist klar
dass ein zweiter locker und so wie wir
in dem früher hatten enorm teuer wäre
das kostet wachstum das kostet
arbeitsplätze das führt zu weiteren
ausgaben des staates die wir schulden
finanzieren müssten
das ist zu verhindern das ist klar ist
es aber auch so dass die worte der
kanzlerin unsicherheit mit sich bringen
dass sie die bevölkerung verängstigen
und das hat wieder selbst einen
wirtschaftlichen effekt natürlich wird
man gerade dabei uns zu erholen von
dieser krise und jetzt sieht so aus als
ob dieser aufholprozess zum ende kommt
und was mir auch wichtig ist ist dass
wir wenn wir die infektionszahlen
ansehen die inzidenz rate die jetzt
deutschlandweit 250 kommt dass wir dem
kontext 10 richtigen kontext sehen dass
diese welle die wir jetzt haben einfach
ganz anders ist als die welle im
frühjahr jetzt bin ich kein
epidemiologen aber eines ist klar wir
testen sehr viel mehr nicht nur mehr
sondern auch andere bevölkerungsgruppen
und das heißt wir sollten nicht so wie
das kaninchen auf die schlange hier auf
diese zahlen gucken und die zum
fertigmachen
das erscheint mir übertrieben und es
führt auch zu falschen
schlussfolgerungen denke ich wenn wir
uns andere länder an seen rund um
deutschland frankreich zum beispiel dass
seit mitte august über einer inzidenz
rate von 50 liegt und wo wir feststellen
müssen
die sterblichkeit dort ist nicht in dem
in dem ausmaß angestiegen wie die
fallzahlen das vermuten ließen also ich
ein bisschen mehr gelassenheit denke ich
wäre es nicht nur virtuell dabei ist das
ein fetisch die zahl 50 nein das ist
gerade fertig also an der zahl würde ich
auch nicht unbedingt hängen aber was
folgendes also ist man feststellen
schlicht und ergreifend die
sterblichkeit dann auch so saß co 2 ist
alters adjustiert nicht besser geworden
was heißt also sagen wir die 75 jährige
die es im frühjahr gekommen
bekommen haben sie hatten genau die das
risiko zu sterben wie die jetzt wie es
jetzt bekommen das ist ein fakt ist
nicht besser ist es leider hat sich
keine mutation ergeben nichts das risiko
ist bleibt nach posen war den
85-jährigen ausstirbt ungefähr jeder
vierte
egal was wir machen im übrigen ist auch
so sehr ist die behandlung macht keinen
großen unterschied das ist erst einmal
dass ich erlebe ich bin ab gute freunde
und kontakte aus meiner haver zahl noch
zu arbeit medical school
wir haben auf der intensivstation keine
besseren behandlungsergebnissen als wir
im kreiskrankenhaus weil einfach die
behandlung ich werde das ist das problem
ist wir haben einfach in den monaten die
wir gehabt haben keine behandlung
hinbekommt
das bedeutet für die deutsche
bevölkerung mit der alte
die sterblichkeit in der bevölkerung
hängt am stärksten davon ab wie viele
infizierten gibt es in dem land
und wie ist das durchschnittsalter der
bevölkerung die infizierten zahl das ist
woher kubicki guard gesagt hat das
sollten wir nicht darauf achten das
halte ich aber für sehr relevant und
zwar deshalb weil wir die andere zahl
auf die es ankommt die alters
zusammensetzung unserer bevölkerung
nicht mehr verändern können europa ist
ein alter kontinent und wir sind
innerhalb europas ein altes land das
heißt wir und dieses eine prozent die
sterblichkeit einer von 100 infizierten
stirbt das ist ja nur zu schaffen wenn
wir nie die überlassung des systems
hätten das sonst geht das ja noch in die
höhe und das alle 9 prozent ausgegangen
waren dass ich mich einmal frau
ostermann mit in die diskussion nehmen
eine junge unternehmerin rossmann auch
an sie die frage wenn sie das jetzt hier
erleben wie die politiker miteinander
streiten über die frage was da das
richtige ist und was die zahlen angeht
was wie wirkt das auf sie
ich bin einfach sehr frustriert weil ich
finde dass gewisse dinge einfach
vorhersehbar sind wir wissen alle dass
jetzt der herz da ist dass der winter
bald kommt ich komme aus dem ehemals
corona hotspot haben inzwischen sind ja
auch andere orte noch stark betroffen
wir waren einer der ersten wo große
hochzeitsfeier stattgefunden haben und
superschnell wahnsinnig viele infizierte
plötzlich da waren und ich bin hier mit
malen unternehmen versorge jeden tag
dafür dass im unternehmen die
rahmenbedingungen so sind dass die
mitarbeiter dort gesund bleiben und eben
auch weiterarbeiten können
und jetzt müssen so viele in quarantäne
unsere berufsschüler könnte teilweise
nicht mehr zur berufsschule gehen und
wir müssen jeden tag einfach richtig
hart dafür kämpfen dass wir weiter eine
gute und beim kunden übrigens hätte die
da hätte die politik denn aus ihrer
sicht machen müssen er unterbinden was
hätten und was hätte die politik anders
machen können aus ihrer sicht
und anfang an hätte erst bundesweit und
nicht regional immer verschieden
festgelegt werden müssen in welchem
rahmen feiern überhaupt jetzt noch
stattfinden dürfen also es ist ja auch
klar erwiesen dass bei privaten feiern
im privaten rahmen infektionen wirklich
auch entstehen das heißt man muss da
wirklich auch tätig werden wo die
infektions stück waren eben auch
entstehen und das ist in deutschland
ganz klar dass eben private feiern der
auslöser sind für diese hohen
infektionszahlen und da hätte ich mir
wirklich gewünscht dass unsere politik
deutlich voraus schauen da auch ist und
hier auch deutlich härter durchgreift
sind dann ist es insgesamt natürlich
deutlich entspannter und wir kommen auch
von einem zweiten lok da und absichtlich
ihre frage ich glaube ihre frage direkt
weiter an den verkehrsminister an die
scheuer der auch in kona kabinett sitzt
etwas falsch rüber also ich bin sehr
dankbar dass die ostermann noch mal
klarmacht dass wir alle vernünftig sein
müssen
ich glaube es ist gar kein widerspruch
zwischen wolfgang kubicki und mir wenn
ich sage wir müssen auch der jungen
generation auch denen die große
hochzeitsfeier machen einfach vermitteln
es ist jetzt nicht notwendig zu feiern
verschiebt eine feier aber jetzt ist
nicht die zeit zu feiern und aus den
worten von herrn kubicki habe ich
herausgehört das ist auch seine
botschaft ist jetzt ist das ein bisschen
im widerspruch zu dem was er vorher
gesagt hat der staat nichts aber wenn
ich jetzt hier durch berlin laufen in
den vergangenen wochen und monaten
tatsächlich die torstraße zum beispiel
im zentrum berlins gefüllt wenig
polizeikontrollen wenig kontrollen
warum ist man da nicht hervorgegangen
deswegen haben wir ja auf initiative der
bundeskanzlerin diversen
ministerpräsidenten konferenzen die auch
klar machen der ministerpräsident
bayerns geht es sehr sehr strikten weg
und die kann kontrolliert auch auf alle
anderen ministerpräsidenten
ich kann ja nicht für den regierenden
bürgermeister in berlin reden ich sehe
es auch was hier los ist an diesem
wochenende glaube ich ist ein bisschen
der groschen gefallen und es war weniger
los aber trotzdem weil man über
statistiken reden ich habe aus der bank
sind so ein
splitter mir rausgerissen von einer von
einer leitenden oberärztin am
universitätsklinikum essen carola
holzner also deckt das was professor
lauterbach sagt ich schaue ihn nicht
mehr auf die korona statistik ich erlebe
sie heute baums ich glaube dass er sehr
sehr beeindruckender beitrag wenn wir
jetzt über statistiken green ja jetzt
kann ich mir auch gedanken machen über
statistiken die der eine wissenschaftler
macht und andere wissenschaftler macht
nur fakt ist wenn ich die situation in
frankreich beispielsweise anschauen dann
hat der präsident mal grob gesagt wir
sind schon eigentlich im zweiten
lockdown und jetzt ist ausgangssperre
und das was frau aus der man sagt das
würde ich mir auch wünschen
einfach zu sagen als unternehmer wie sie
unternehmerschaft repräsentiert uns
wurde gedankt als bundesregierung dass
wir sehr sehr viele maßnahmen sofort
ergriffen haben zum hilfe der wirtschaft
jetzt geht es darum die vernunft in der
bevölkerung so hinzubekommen dass die
die wirklich drauf schauen die
unternehmer die gastronomen die
hoteliers hygiene konzepte machen neue
geschäftsideen haben vieles wir um diese
harte zeit zu überbrücken darf nicht der
ausreißer sein dass 380 irgendwann in
einem kleinen saal feiern und dann
plötzlich ein hotspot in der region
ausbricht da muss müssen wir jetzt echt
haut zeigen möchte noch einmal über die
sprache und die worte sprechen frau sah
man möchte noch etwas hinzufügen groß
aber ich möchte unbedingt wie wichtig
ist das wir feiern unterbinden damit
kinder zur schule gehen können und in
kitas gehen können und dass wir unsere
arbeit weiter nachgehen können denn wir
müssen ja schließlich unsere existenz
erwirtschaften wir wollen unsere
familien ernähren aber auch dass unser
system bezahlen und das muss irgendwie
neben unserer gesundheit es wirklich im
vordergrund stehen und dann muss das
privatvergnügen jetzt einfach mal
zurückstehen dass es auch hier
verzichten muss einfach bei allen
bürgern jetzt mal möglich sein und so
viel vernunft aber schon noch mal an sie
die frage während das nicht unterbunden
wurde in den vergangenen wochen und
monaten streiten sie über das
beherbergungs verbot
naja jetzt lassen wir mal ein thema mal
beiseite auch das thema versorgung mit
masken da könnt ihr jetzt einmal kubik
beantworten dass der minister sparen
jetzt 90.000
masken paket geschnürt für alle
einrichtungen also jetzt noch mal vom
herbst und winter es werden ja jeden tag
maßnahmen gemacht natürlich wurde das
beherbergungs verbot hochgezogen
natürlich mit den entscheidungen der
gerichte nicht jede entscheidung ist
richtig wir lernen ja ständig auch dazu
politik hat jetzt corona genauso viele
fragezeichen und und offene fragen wir
lernen jede woche dazu das ist
wahrscheinlich bei den wissenschaftlern
genauso und da kommt eine maßnahme die
wir besser und eine wird schlechter aber
das war es vor ostern man sagt da bin
ich echt dankbar darüber genau dies ist
der link jetzt vernünftig zu sein auch
ein bisschen streng zu sein die privaten
feiern reduzieren weil wenn wir das
nicht tun dann leidet wirtschaft runter
und dann gibt es wirklich in die
schulschließungen kindergarten
schließungen unternehmensschließungen
oder lockdown in unternehmen genau das
ist der link jetzt zu sagen hört auf und
vernünftig zu sein
geben wir konzentriert an die sache
heran die nächsten monate dann sparen
wir uns hinten raus die große belastung
für wirtschaft und gesellschaft viel
über feiern
herr kubicki eine frage an sie gerichtet
wenn man über diese feiern spricht was
es aus ihrer sicht da der tatsächliche
hintergrund und was bedeutet es
eigentlich dass jetzt die kanzlerin und
der regierungssprecher aktuell zum
beispiel in der videobotschaft auch
vermehrt mit arabischen untertiteln
arbeiten um sozusagen auch menschen mit
migrationshintergrund zu erreichen
sehen sie da eine problematik die
bislang zumindest der öffentlichkeit
wenig diskutiert wurde
also zunächst angehalten freue ich mich
mehr denn unsere freunde erklärte torri
sein
bayern hat die höchsten instanz seinen
höchsten todesraten trotz der massiven
aktivitäten von der zürich kommen wir
schließlich deutschland sind
vergleichsweise gut da vor wir haben bei
uns in geschlossenen räumen
feierlichkeiten egal welche art mit mehr
als 50 personen untersagt da hat sich
auch jeder gehalten
wir erleben aber in nordrhein westfalen
und berlin das feierlichkeiten für bis
zu 1000 personen zugelassen worden sind
gesundheitsämtern insbesondere bei
großen gegeben türkischen kurdischen und
arabischen großfamilien wörtlich steht
deutschland zwei große ausbrüche bei den
heidenern flensburg von familien mit
migrationshintergrund in deutschland
nicht feiern konnten deshalb nach
stockholm oder auflagen gefahren sind
und dann endlich infektionsdruck
gekommen sind
wir müssen aufpassen dass es nicht in
die falsche richtung läuft das hat was
mit dem kulturellen eigenheiten zu tun
dass menschen altern enger miteinander
umgehen bei fälligkeiten als wir das im
norden jedenfalls gewöhnt in dessen
bayern ist aber jedenfalls müssen wir
darauf dafür sorge tragen dass in
geschlossen räumen nur eine bestimmte
personengruppe feiern kann bei uns gibt
es ein tanzverbot bei uns gibt es einen
link verbot darüber kann man auch lange
diskutieren über jedenfalls hat das dazu
geführt dass bei uns die sträucher
infektionszahlen noch vergleichsweise
niedrig und beherrschbar sind und dabei
soll es auch bleiben
wenig hat das ovg schleswig ich teile
diese entscheidung nicht das
beherbergungs verboten steht deutschland
bestätigt und jetzt wieder das
bewerbungs verbot freiwillig in bayern
abgeschafft so weit ist das eben er laut
aber sehen sie ähnlich wie herr kubicki
ein besonderes problem und eine die
frage ob es ein besonderes aufklärung
bedarf für menschen mit
migrationshintergrund oder ist das
quatsch
kein quatsch das muss man natürlich
einräumen war kulturelle unterschiede
und auch also sprachbarrieren bei der
ansprache spielen hier natürlich eine
große rolle von daher wäre es falsch das
nicht einzuräumen
ich würde also in einem punkt hier
klartext sprechen der punkt wo wir also
das noch in den griff hätten bekommen
können also wir kämen aus dem
exponentiellen wachstum heraus indem wir
einfach nur die feiern verbieten ist
leider von weg der das hätte man vor
zwei oder drei wochen vielleicht noch
machen können hat man das nicht gemacht
das sah ich blicke nach vorne und nicht
nach hinten also das ist uninteressant
also ich muss schauen wo wir jetzt sind
und diagnose ist die und deinhard merkel
recht ab indem sie auf die kontakte
abgehoben hat vor zwei wochen hätte
wahrscheinlich noch gereicht wenn wir
einfach die feiern die privaten feiern
begrenzt hätten da gab's modellierungen
auf 25 leute maximal das wäre
möglicherweise noch gegangen aber jetzt
haben wir so viele fälle in der breiten
bevölkerung dass die ganz gewöhnlichen
kontakte am arbeitsplatz im restaurant
dass die auch schon reichen sozusagen
die pandemie zu unterhalt das heißt sie
wollen wieder alles dichtmachen
ich will ich nicht ich will nur erklären
also dass tatsächlich dass wir jetzt
jeder einzelne die kontakte reduzieren
müssen und ich halte es für extrem
gefährlich also folgenden er da ihre
gedanken sollen das werden sie haben
mein fehler so könnte man falsch denkt
ein falsches denken wir jetzt im moment
wie folgt ich mache keine privaten
feiern ich bin nicht betroffen
ich mache ich gehe ich sogar eine
hochzeitsfeier ich kann das machen was
ich in den letzten drei wochen gemacht
habe ich verändere mich nicht weil ich
habe ja gar ich gehöre nicht zu diesen
also groß feiern und zwar das hätte vor
ein paar wochen hat das gereicht die
zeit ist vorbei das ist abgefahren jetzt
ist die zahl mittlerweile so hoch und
das hat sich so stark verbreitet dass
wir jetzt tatsächlich an die ich sag mal
nicht feier kontakte haben müssen
und das müssen wir schnell machen was
sonst sind wir in einer solchen feier
und sind in frankreich schon lange
verboten
und trotzdem sind die mehr oder weniger
locker und weil wir nicht einmal eine
gewisse zahl von infizierten erreicht
habe
dann sind die früchte die tief hängender
ökonom spricht davon den tief hängenden
früchte der tief hängenden früchte die
feiern aus die großveranstaltungen und
zwar so die klaren hochzeiten die frühen
früchte die sind jetzt alle
wie relevant jetzt muss ich an die
höheren früchte heran und daher wird das
schwieriger werden und ich will einfach
dem der illusion entgegenwirken dass wir
jetzt sagen können werden die feiern
jetzt erst mal beendet sind dann sind
wir aus dem schneider der punkt ist
nicht mehr der fall wenn man über eine
möglichkeit spricht um diesen shutdown
lockdown wie auch immer noch zu
verhindern wird auch darüber nachgedacht
ob man bestimmte risikogebiete abriegeln
könnte also wir senden hier aus
berlin-mitte könnten könnte könnte man
sagen man macht jetzt berlin mitte dicht
keiner kann die mal raus ist das eine
möglichkeit um einen gesamt shutter und
so dahin ja das wäre jedenfalls eine
sehr drakonische maßnahme wir haben das
ja erlebt wo hahn wurde so abgeregelt
das hat irgendwie funktioniert wir sehen
uns jetzt in madrid da funktioniert
nicht so toll die stadt wurde
abgeriegelt
die frage ist wie man das durchsetzen
kann dann müsste man also massiv
wahrscheinlich mit polizeikräften
arbeiten die menschen müssten sich daran
halten
aber wäre besser als locker und
wahrscheinlich das ja absolut also ich
denke was wir sicherlich nicht wieder
machen sollten ist winter ersten welle
einen sein ansatz der für das ganze
bundesgebiet derselbe wäre
wir müssen also differenzieren ich
glaube das ist ein vorteil des
föderalismus das ist zwar natürlich mit
kommunikationsproblem betrachtet aber
das müssen wir hinkriegen dass das lokal
machen erscheinen wäre das eine
möglichkeit ich erinnere mich im
frühjahr als es losging haben sie damals
die bundeswehr ins spiel gebracht und
haben gesagt wir brauchen die bundeswehr
um massiv mit zu helfen könnte es so
weit kommen dass am ende die bundeswehr
einzelne risikogebiete abriegeln muss ja
die bundeswehr hilft ja gott sei dank
jetzt schon mit bei den vielen nach
verfolgungen und vieles mehr auch der
ministerpräsident sachsens fordert auch
noch mal eine ausweitung des engagements
da sieht man schon dass sich in den
letzten monaten unglaublich viel
entwickelt hat was die die das
ablaufende einer krise bedeutet ich
möchte selber mal vielleicht noch den
gedanken formulieren im lockdown gab es
aber immer noch bereiche die gut
funktioniert haben also wir haben es
geschafft dass alle baustellen die der
bund macht also auf den verkehrswegen
dass die weiterhin bearbeitet werden
versteht das verkehrsminister auch über
baustellen spreche ja meine frage war
aber arbeitshilfen was ist mit der
abriegelung der risikogebiete ja ich
will mir aber nicht gerade ausmalen was
eine abriegelung von einem von der stadt
oder von einer kleinen einheit die
hotspot ist bedeutet ist natürlich muss
man szenarien so durchspielen nur ich
ich will daniela hat zum beispiel vom rk
ii hat auch schon gesagt das sei eine
theoretische möglichkeit also liegt ja
auch eher theoretisch in anführung sein
also haben sie jetzt selber formuliert
theoretisch natürlich muss man sich das
mal vorstellen was das bedeutet was
notwendig ist bei dem ausbruch in einem
großen schlachtbetrieb hat man so einen
so einen kleinen fall schon mal getestet
ja es wäre eine möglichkeit nur ich will
nicht dran denken sondern wir wollen es
ja wir wollen ja wieder vor die welle
kommen und den stop damit auslösen aber
noch einmal wenn wir das vergleichen
felber märz gesagt es wäre am ende
besser als der komplette shutter und
eines landes wenn man einzelne
risikogebiete abriegelt sehen sie das
genauso ja hat am anfang beispielsweise
ganz am anfang ja für gewisse landkreise
auch funktioniert beispielsweise in
meiner bayerischen heimat gab es einen
so einen frühen fall im landkreis
tirschenreuth wo man solche themen ja
schon hatte das ist ja nichts neues aber
ich will jetzt doch nicht mit
martialischen wortschatz aufwarten weil
das wäre wirklich
einigung drehung zu viel aber man muss
natürlich daran denken wie man diese
darum heißt ja hotspots so einschränkt
dass nicht das ganze land betroffen ist
laut aber es gibt auch noch eine
alternative natürlich ist das muss
überdacht werden dass also will man
nicht komplett ausschließen gar keine
frage es gibt auch noch eine alternative
heute ist eine sehr interessante arbeit
erschienen wo man in england sich also
ähnliche gedanken machen da gab es eine
sehr gute modellierung die den
ökonomischen und die medizinischen
folgen abgesetzt hat von einem
befristeten angekündigten schatten firma
mit wegen zwei wochen über das ganze
land dass sie nicht auf eine region
begrenzt sodass das plan war ist und
nach dem motto in drei wochen von jetzt
machen wir für zwei wochen einen
shutdown
so dass wir dann die infektionszahlen
deutlich runter fahren in dieser zeit
und danach kommt das leben wieder ein
stück war doch das kabel oder ravidass
solider sogar halten sie das für wie
wahrscheinlich halten sie das dass wir
am ende
es war eine abriegelung von neukölln von
berlin mitte oder zahl ich da das hängt
einfach sehr stark davon ab ich habe ja
eben schon gesagt das hängt davon ab was
in den letzten drei wochen passiert wenn
wir in den nächsten drei wochen
sozusagen nicht drastisch etwas
verändern wenn das drama der appell von
merkel und von uns allen funktioniert
nicht es wurde nicht funktioniert dann
kommt das natürlich war dann sind wir
genau auf dem weg unterwegs noch immer
dann kommt natürlich eine abriegelung
risiko gibt ja oder eine andere form
ich habe ja gerade noch eine alternative
versucht zu erklären bevor die
unterbrechung kam aber lange wir müssten
dann irgendetwas machen was drastisch
ist da hat mir herr kubicki schüttelt
seit mehreren minuten mit dem kopf
herr kubicki wie sehen dass ich die
frage der abriegelung nicht richtig
finde ich finde die diskussion über
unglaublich also kann bei andreas
scheuer geworden doch ein rest von
rechtsstaatlichkeit vorhanden gerade
eben das abriegeln
das grundgesetz gilt auch während andere
pandemie das abregeln ganzer ortschaften
also man stellt das noch vor hamburg von
der bundeswehr gestellt und kann daher
kann ja auch mal aus dass er so absurd
dass man das gar nicht diskutieren
sollte weil es die menschen noch weiter
dieser treibt das ist eine kleine pots
potts unter quarantäne stellen kann und
ein und ausreisen behindern kann nicht
für zielführend ist ja auch teilweise
gemacht worden aber die überlegung dass
wir ganze ortschaften abregeln dh
verhindern dass mensch
diese orte verlassen können wir
zurückkommen können ist unter der
geltung des grundgesetzes unvorstellbar
und ich wundere mich dass diese
diskussion geführt werden es wird zeit
dass der deutsche bundestag die mit
diesen fragen beschäftigt das nicht
läuten überlässt jedem hinterzimmern
dann wir bestimmte ideen nach wenn das
parlament unsere aufgabe jetzt nicht
wahrnehmen kann hat die demokratie einen
dauerhaften schaden ist aufgabe des
parlaments wesentlich entscheidungen zu
treffen
die aufgabe von hat aber vor allem eins
beweisen warum der kollege kubicki so
aggressiv heute ist keiner hat irgendwie
gesprochen dass man mit der bundeswehr
nord abriegeln will sondern hat wir
haben darüber gesprochen aber auch
lösungsansätze wären für hot spots also
konstruieren und und vielleicht ärgern
dass er irgendwie jetzt gerade weg ist
aus dem studio und versucht jetzt da
irgendwelche worte im mund umzudrehen
uns geht es doch alle darum dass wir
jetzt den stop erreichen und zweitens
natürlich verlieren wir alle zusammen in
der gesellschaft die geduld mit diesem
virus
wir wollen nicht mehr ständig
eingeschränkt werden dass wir irgendwie
gute freundin nicht umarmen können aber
es ist heute mal so und deswegen müssen
wir jetzt die lösung finden damit wir
dann in den wintermonaten wo auch
weihnachten drinnen ist ein einigermaßen
normales weihnachten und eine
besinnliche zeit haben zum jahreswechsel
nicht noch weiterhin dramatik in unserer
situation dort wollen sie die verfassung
brechen sowie hab ich das sagt nein also
zunächst haben wir haben ja alles was
wir bisher gemacht haben
durch das parlament und auch durch die
also fassungs gremien immer prüfen
lassen und diese prüfung müssen
stattfinden und zwar sehr eng und streng
und damit natürlich auch herrn kubicki
immer dankbar dass er da auf mögliche
schwierigkeiten hin was das vollkommen
legitim und gehört hier hin
aber wir müssen trotzdem sagen es gibt
keine denkverbote und man muss das art
kollege steuerrecht wir müssen auch
darüber nachdenken wir haben ja jetzt
sozusagen darüber gesprochen was ja
niemand von uns wünscht dass wir das in
den nächsten drei wochen nicht
beherrschte kommen dann kommt an sehr
dass muss man ganz ehrlich sagen dann
kommt ein steiler weg und zwar bergab
und den wollen wir um uns herum schon
überall sehen das ist
jetzt gehört die sicherung sagen wohin
uns die habe ich einer geordneten ich
bin ja optimistisch dass wir es schaffen
und dann muss es doch gestartet zahlen
dass wir uns überlegen was sind die
maßnahmen die am wenigsten anschneiden
sind oder täusche ich mich ja und ich
habe nur eine störung an einem eigenen
nachfolger die studie kommt mit einmal
dr kubicki sie wollten noch darauf
antworten ich wollte dass ein liter karl
lauterbach nicht wir haben über 60
gerichtsentscheidungen die im
eilverfahren der in der regierungsnahen
ländern und im bund bestätigt haben dass
sie sich rechts oder verpasst du dich
verhalten da das ist in einem
rechtsstaat kaum hinnehmbar ziehen
entscheidung vom hundert ist schon der
menge heute sagen muss das parlament
mehr tun das was sie gerade beschrieben
und meine frage ist jetzt auch ans
steuer
warum die kanzlerin nicht die behören
bürger aufgefordert hat sfb zwei masken
zu bekommen sich zu tragen denn das ist
sein eigenschutz an können sich nicht
anstecken warum kapelle zu hause zu
bleiben sozusagen vollzogen aber keine
appelle sieben richtige masken aus
zustand nicht so ich würde gerne einmal
vor ausser man die möglichkeit im herbst
sie wollten zu der thematik
sie wollten zu der thematik was die
mögliche abriegelung von risikogebieten
angeht glaube ich auch etwas sagen
ja zum thema doch dann egal ob im ganzen
bundesland oder einzeln union oder stadt
immer aus diese verhältnismäßigkeit ja
auch immer im blick behalten
es bringt uns ja nichts wenn wir unsere
komplette wirtschaft kaputt machen ich
habe mir das gerade bild nicht
vorgestellt wenn unsere kommen region
komplett abgeriegelt ist dann kann ich
die bude dichtmachen bei uns zu hause
was ist dann mit den 200 arbeitsplätzen
diese ganzen existenz in diesen sachen
kaputt also natürlich ist es wichtig
diese gesundheit im blick behalten aber
wir müssen ja schließlich ganzheitlich
die dinge betrachten und auch uns
überlegen was es sonst noch für
auswirkungen hat es bringt uns nichts
wenn wir unsere komplette wirtschaft
kaputt machen wir damit ja schließlich
auch unser sehr gutes gesundheitssystem
bezahlen und die möglichkeit geben sie
haben blick auf die gesamtwirtschaft
situation in deutschland wie dramatisch
ist ist bereits und wie schlimm kann es
noch werden
wir haben eine dramatische phase gehabt
ihm früher die ist vorbei und wir haben
jetzt eine verlangsamung wider
das ist jetzt in den letzten gutachten
wieder deutlich geworden dass das foul
nicht mehr so steil weiter geht wie wir
uns das gerne wünschen und das hat schon
wieder zu tun mit den zunehmenden
infektionszahlen es gibt eine klare eine
klare beziehung zwischen diesen dingen
in dem ihr infektionsgeschehen umso mehr
schränken sich die menschen teilweise
auch freiwillige braucht es gar keine
moralpredigten der kanzlerin der braucht
auch gar keinen lockten die menschen die
sich anstecken keiner von uns will die
krankheit haben und das wird
wirtschaftlich durchschlagen jetzt ist
wie alle sagen hier die frage wie kann
man die das infektionsgeschehen ein
themen ohne das wird dabei wieder diese
hohen kosten eingehen die wir im
frühjahr hatten und ich hoffe sehr dass
wir gelernt haben aus den aus den ersten
erfahrungen dass wir heute besser wissen
wo das infektionsgeschehen stattfindet
und dass man dort konkret einschreitet
ich weiß nicht ob es richtig ist die
leute vor den reisen zu warnen so
pauschal oder ob es nicht viel mehr
geboten wäre dort wo das
infektionsgeschehen passiert bei den
familienfeiern sehr viel drakonischer
mit höheren strafen und stärkerer
kontrolle sich einzuschreiten sie
sprechen die verängstigung der menschen
der verunsicherung der menschen an
ich würde ihnen gerne mal allen ein foto
zeigen was aufgenommen wurde in
großburgwedel
bibel bei hannover dort sehen wir das
und wir kennen auch das aus dem frühjahr
bereits kein klopapier mehr vorhanden
ist teilweise so erzählte uns der ihn
die das foto aufgenommen hat er dann in
einem anderen bereich auch nur eine
packung kaufen durfte weil das sozusagen
schon bereits rationiert wurde also hat
die kanzlerin mit ihrer rede für panik
gesorgt da schon nein hat sie nicht weil
man muss ja sagen selbst für einen lock
down haben wir es geschafft deutschland
zu versorgen versorgt zu sein in allen
handelns und einen anderen klubs nicht
genug ausreichend na ja also ich habe
glaube ich 150 telefonkonferenzen und
videokonferenzen nur zu den wundern sich
und es war natürlich spitzen da wenn
plötzlich wirkliche hamsterkäufe gemacht
wird aber es war nie ein notstand an
dieser stelle da und auf jeden fall über
alle versorgungs artikel war immer eine
grundversorgung sichergestellt im
übrigen auch unsinn vergessen können sie
können sie garantieren den deutschen
dass genügend klopapier davon wird aber
als klopapier alleine kommen sie nicht
an gott sei dank
also ich sage ich bin ja auch schon hier
gesessen er in der hochphase von
lockdown die bahn hat eine stabile
grundversorgung möglich gemacht im
passagierverkehr und güterverkehr
wir haben die supermärkte versorgt mit
unseren vom brummifahrer angefangen bis
zum gabelstapler fahrer bis zu den
logistikern die jeden tag hart die
arbeit geleistet haben also ich versteh
oft unsere diskussion nicht wenn man im
ausland über deutsche situationen in
lockdown phasen und in corona pandemien
redet dann ist nur bewunderung da wie
wir diese situation diese
außerordentliche situation gemanagt
haben und auch mit den hilfen für die
unternehmen natürlich würde die frau
ostermann wenn ein lock down by ear wäre
bei diesem hotspot nicht alleine
gelassen
also ich bin in vielen runden mit
wirtschaftsvertretern zusammen das erste
das immer kommt ist danke dass die
bundesregierung
dass die politik so schnell gehandelt
hat mit vielen vielen hilfen dann mag
man die eine oder andere entscheidung
was die kurzarbeit betrifft anderer
meinung sein okay aber das was unser
ausland macht hat ist dass wir schützen
und stützen wirklich umgesetzt was uns
über die anderen länder um uns herum
sprechen wo die situation ja tatsächlich
dramatischer ist wir sehen frankreich
wir sind in tschechien schwächen kommen
wir später noch einmal
kann es sein dass wir wieder mit
grenzschließung jetzt rechnen müssen
oder bringt das aus ihrer sicht nichts
ja wir müssen noch mal die situation
anschauen wie sie sich weiterentwickelt
aber ich sag mal schon besorgnis er
irgendwas um uns herum passiert immer
noch ein normales politikerleben in der
eu ratspräsidentschaft ist er nicht nur
mal die die deutsche ratspräsidentschaft
ist so wichtig für europa wir tragen
aber nur nur digital also das heißt
natürlich hat das immense auswirkungen
und auch da muss der appell von europa
ausgehen
alle die in europa wirklich nicht
unbedingt reisen müssen sollen es sein
lassen hat aber sich als experte bringen
grenzschließung etwas aus köln sich
summen bringen dann etwas wenn ein land
extrem hohe zahlen hat und das andere
land ist noch wenig betroffen dann
bringt das hat sich etwas aber das
deutet sich an dass wir nur wenige
wochen quasi hinter den nachbarländern
hinterher sind also man darf den
vorsprung im sinne von uns geht's noch
besser den darf man nicht überschätzen
das ist also eine sache von zwei drei
wochen sah es kann sein dass wir es
jetzt gestoppt bekommen
dann wurden wir einen sonderweg gehen
eine kurze zwischenfrage aber wenn sie
sagen dass wir jetzt noch besser
dastehen als andere darauf müsste man
dann nicht nach ihrer logik jetzt sagen
und im moment ist das im moment
verändert sich die lage bei uns wenn
sich weiter verändert weder allein wegen
der feiern noch wegen auto raserei ins
land hinein oder in deutschland sondern
im moment haben wir die situation dass
die lotter hat mir drin
es haben sich schon mittlerweile in den
letzten wochen so viele angestellt was
man sich drinnen gegenseitig infiziert
und zwar in den familien in den
betrieben in den schulen und zwar
überall
das heißt nicht nur bei feiern jetzt ist
einfach der faktor der zwei dinge kommen
zusammen es sind schon viele
geziert und das zweites man geht nach
drinnen da nützen übrigens auch die fsb
zwei masken von herrn kubicki
ich kann ja nicht drin mit meiner
familie oder im betrieb habe ich später
effect 2 ausgetragen
ich bin also heute mit einer
spezialmaske der bahn gekommen weil die
werde das abteil war ziemlich voll
aber da müssen sie schon ordentlich
ziehen wenn sie die außer stundenlang an
haben somit das problem was man jetzt
hat das ging sie damit nicht mehr gelöst
sie waren im übrigen weitgehend
pünktlich unterwegs ja das stimmt das
muss ich ausnahmsweise einräumen ist
sogar der zug komplett gefahren der wahl
sonst über der halbe zugausfälle habe
dazu später mehr
die idee es ist aber trotzdem so etwas
also jetzt ist es so also das wird jetzt
nicht durch das reißen verursacht daher
war auch die gesamte diskussion um das
beherbergungs verbot in deutschland
total schädigt davon hin so gut wie
nichts ab egal wie man uns entschieden
hat und es hat uns diskreditiert war so
aussah als wenn wir uns in einer sache
die nicht so wichtig ist nicht einigen
können das dürfen wir uns nicht zu oft
leisten
er fällt mal wenn ich ihn richtig
verstanden hat kann er kennt schließung
nicht ausschließen der lauter was sagt
ist kann gegebenenfalls etwas bringen
momentan eher nicht was würde es
bedeuten für die wirtschaft wenn auch in
europa wieder grenzen geschlossen wird
ja die frage ist ob man wirklich die
grenzen komplett schließen muss oder ob
man nicht sagen kann
für den gütertransport zum beispiel
bleiben die grenzen offen oder für für
geschäftsreisende bleiben sie offen für
andere personen vielleicht nicht oder
nicht im selben ausmass und nur unter
bestimmten bedingungen und ich glaube
wir müssen hier differenzieren und wir
können das auch denn wir haben die die
wir haben in einem halben jahr in dem
wir mit dem virus leben eben auch schon
denke ich dazugelernt man wissen wie das
virus weiter geht dann ein spediteur der
waren nach deutschland bringen dass
italien und zurück ich glaube nicht dass
das die quelle ist wo die infektion
haben bis zeit ist ja auch geregelt ist
ja jetzt schon geregelt war im lok dann
geregelt ist für die zukunft geregelt
alles was güterverkehr ist was
versorgung ist es auch
grenzüberschreitender logistischer
notwendiger verkehr aufgeteilt nach
verschiedenen berufsgruppen also da
wurde ja schon intelligent vorgearbeitet
schon die ganze zeit wir haben
beispielsweise für
reisen einstimmig den deutschen
vorschlag in europa angenommen über die
verhaltensregeln also mund und
nasenschutz hygiene-vorschriften kürzere
intervalle des reinigen desinfizieren
das haben alle europäischen
mitgliedsstaaten auf vorschlag umgesetzt
sprechen europa an wir haben reporter in
zwei länder geschickt die in gewisser
weise in der extreme gegen
gegenüberstehen
zum einen möchte ich nach tschechien
blicken in der situation wir haben es
gerade schon angesprochen die zahlen
sind dort dramatisch und meine kollegin
die arminia war dort und hat sich auf
eine intensivstation beginnen die
tschechischen hauptstadt prag steht
wieder still
so wie der rest des landes doch die
korona intensivstationen laufen auf
hochtouren
in der kleinstadt la nahe prag behandeln
die ärzte ausschließlich patienten die
an coo wird 19 leiden und einen
besonders schweren krankheitsverlauf
durch machen
jeden tag bekommen wir neue patienten
und wir haben kaum noch kapazitäten
zehn von zehn betten sind belegt
aufgrund der hohen infektionszahlen baut
die klinik nun ihre station aus bei
einigen ist nicht sicher ob sie das
virus am ende überleben werden wie bei
diesem herrn der 60 jährige mann wird
schon seit fünf tagen beatmet bisher ist
keine besserung in sicht
jetzt gehen wir zu herrn chronik das
corona virus hat 35 prozent seiner lunge
befallen
leider hat er sich jetzt noch eine
weitere infektion der unteren atemwege
zugezogen
dr batu untersucht jeden tag die lunge
des patienten sein zustand ist kritisch
es geht um leben und tod
das gesundheitswesen steht vor dem
kollaps
täglich stecken sich um die 8000
menschen neu mit co wird 19 an
allein in den letzten vier wochen sind
fünf menschen dem virus erlegen
es gibt auch um die kapazität des
krankenhauses wir haben jetzt schon
unser maximum erreicht wir können die
zahl der pflegekräfte nicht erhöhen
es gibt sie einfach nicht auch die
anzahl der betten ist begrenzt wenn sich
die lage so rapide verschlechtert wie
statistiker angeben kann es passieren
dass es sehr bald an leuten und material
fehlen wird die gute nachricht
deutschland hat sich bereit erklärt
tschechische kuwait patienten
aufzunehmen
ja und uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist meine
kollegin jasmin yavuz die immer noch in
tschechien ist yasemin ich weiß nicht ob
du uns schon hören kannst in jedem fall
da ist es mir beschreibt uns bitte
einmal was du dort auf der
intensivstation erlebt hast und wie
dramatisch die lage in tschechien
mittlerweile schon ist
hallo paula wie du gerade schon erwähnt
hattest wir und wie man auch gesehen
hatte wir hatten die möglichkeit einmal
auf so eine corona intensivstation
blicken zu dürfen
das natürlich unter ganz strengen
auflagen und corona konform
in schutzkleidung das was wir im beitrag
gesehen haben was vermittelt wurde also
dass die menschen und die ärzte eben
dort wirklich an ihre grenzen kommen
dass die betten belegt sind dass es auch
das was wir vor ort wahrgenommen haben
also krankenpflegerinnen und pfleger
haben uns noch zusätzlich erzählt dass
es eben genauso wie in deutschland einen
erheblichen fachkräftemangel gibt also
dass es nicht genug intensiv pfleger und
pflegerinnen gibt um die korona
infizierten die neu infizierten die
jetzt vielleicht noch ins krankenhaus
kommen in den nächsten wochen auf diese
intensivstation
dass diese eben auch nicht mehr
ordentlich versorgt werden können aber
viel besser einschätzen kann dass dr
peter amberger der jetzt hier neben mir
steht er ist der direktor des
universitätsklinikums hier in prag er
spricht deutsch weil er seine famulatur
in münchen und in gießen abgeschlossen
hat herr doktor arnberger vielleicht
könnten sie uns einfach noch einmal
erzählen wie schlimm steht es denn nun
wirklich um tschechien müssen die
krankenhäuser eine zu lockere corona
politik nun ausbaden
also zum beispiel in unserem klinikum
ist das im moment immer noch akzeptable
das heißt wir haben jetzt 60 patienten
mit hus infektion und wir haben elf
patienten
mit der künstlichen beatmung aber ich
kann mir vorstellen weil die zahl die
gesamtzahl der patienten mit krone virus
wachsen jeden tag ganz dramatisch aus
einem am freitag hatten wir mehr als
11.000 neue fälle das heißt im vergleich
zu deutschland wenn wir das auch die
bewohnerzahl umrechnet dann würde das
wie in deutschland 80.000 pro tag neue
fälle
und das heißt dass auch gewisse prozent
dann für die stationäre behandlung nötig
sind und auch also die intensivstationen
werden wahrscheinlich in den nächsten
zwei oder drei wochen ganz voll belegt
und deswegen müssen wird zum beispiel in
unserem krankenhaus wo wir 1100 betten
haben die bettenzahl ein bisschen
umstrukturieren und wir haben zum
beispiel seit freitag eine information
aus dem gesundheitsministerium
dass wir unsere bettenzahl für die
cholera kranke ca 3 mal so ein bis vier
mal vergessen müssen weil wir am rechnet
mit 120 130 betten für cholera kranke
reserviert und wir sollten also bis zu
500 vorbereiten in den nächsten drei
wochen
und das ist schon ziemlich kompliziert
und die kann mir vorstellen dass die
kollegen aus den intensivstationen
das sind ist in tschechien überhaupt auf
diese neue infektionen oder sind die
krankenhäuser dafür gewappnet wenn die
sie jetzt eben sagen 'das um die hälfte
ihrer betten die es überhaupt im
krankenhaus gibt für corona patienten
nun frei gehalten werden müssen
und glauben sie es war ja schon im
gespräch deutschland dass deutschland
vielleicht koma patientin aus tschechien
eben in deutschland behandeln wird
glauben sie dass das geschehen sollte
und wünschen sie sich das vielleicht
auch also meiner ansicht nach müssen
auch diese restriktion maßnahmen die am
mittwoch bei uns gestartet haben wir
haben schulen geschlossen und
restaurants geschlossen
also hoffentlich innerhalb von zwei
wochen sehen wir eine reduzierung von
diesen zahlen aber trotzdem kann
passieren dass wir wirklich so ganz kann
einen engen einen engpass von den
intensivbetten haben und dann würden wir
selbstverständlich gerne wenn uns
deutschland hilft
und das ist die aussage von dr peter
berger hier aus tschechien und damit
gebe ich zurück zur paul ins studio
herzlichen dank yasemin wirklich
dramatische bilder die wir dort gesehen
haben in der intensivstation
lauterbach können wir den tschechen
helfen können wir patienten aufnehmen
ist diese schon das angebot formuliert
wurden der bayerische ministerpräsident
glaube ich hatte schon das angebot an
den nachbarn gegeben intensivpatienten
zu übernehmen
ich sage nochmal bei tschechien und
polen haben wir im märz erlebt als wir
in den lockdown wochen waren das die
polen und die tschechen sehr sehr strikt
gehandelt haben wir hatten da echte
probleme auch mit den logistischen
verkehren
und jetzt sind die zahlen natürlich umso
dramatischer das eigentlich dieses land
schon durch war
wenn man das so sich ansieht und jetzt
wieder so eine gigantische ausbreitung
ist und das gesundheitssystem an den
rand führt zeigt was uns eben nicht
passieren darf und deswegen ist dieses
dieses beispiel aus tschechien sowie ja
wohl weil genau diese folgewirkungen
wären es dann das eben wieder schulen
geschlossen werden müssen kindergärten
geschlossen werden müssen was das wieder
für die eltern als große herausforderung
bedeutet bis hin zu den betrieben und
genau das ist unser hintergrund würden
wir hier sitzen um zu kämpfen dass uns
das nicht noch mal passiert ich möchte
weiter schauen in ein land über das viel
diskutiert worden ist in den vergangenen
monaten und das sozusagen immer ein
bisschen als das gegenbeispiel
aufgeführt wurde nämlich nach schweden
wo meine kollegin annika rasch momentan
ist und sie hat sich dort in schweden
auf die suche begeben wie die situation
heute ist
schönen guten abend
wie nimmt man momentan in schweden die
debatte um höhere infektionszahlen um
die sorge in europa gibt es weiterhin
einen sonderweg oder ist mittlerweile
man auch umgeschwenkt und handelt wie in
deutschland
ja ich bin jetzt seit april mehrmals in
schweden gewesen und ich muss sagen der
weg hat sich eigentlich nicht sonderlich
verändert
man setzt hier weiterhin auf
eigenverantwortung statt auf strikte
maßnahmen und im vergleich zum rest von
europa steht schweden und auch
skandinavien eigentlich ganz gut da
nichtsdestotrotz steigen aber auch hier
die zahlen und das einzige was hier
wirklich sofort ins auge sticht ist das
hier keine masken getragen werden
ich war gestern in einem bus der
komplett voll war mit 30 personen und
gestanden wirklich schulter an schulter
und kein mensch hat eine maske auf
gehabt also natürlich gibt es einen
irgendwie ein schönes gefühl wenn man
denkt es kehrt wieder normalität zurück
aber dann wird aber auch wieder sofort
bewusst auch nie hier ist eben auch
immer noch corona also es ist schon sehr
ungewohnt gerade wenn die leute jetzt
auch im herbst wieder anfangen zu husten
weil sie erkältet sind
ich habe trotzdem das gefühl dass die
schweden relativ früh gemerkt haben dass
corona bleibt und dass wir uns darauf
einstellen müssen dass wir damit noch
mehrere jahre leben müssen und sich
deshalb eine strategie ausgesucht hat
die halt eben auch über mehrere jahre
durchzuführen ist und warum man in
schweden eigentlich immer noch keine
masken trägt darüber würde ich gerne
sprechen mit professor jonas ludwig
sonst vom karolinska institut
er ist jetzt hier neben mir professor
ludwig seinen posten bald facebook
übersetzt sich jetzt einmal also herr
professor ludwig sohn hat gesagt
schweden hat sich deshalb gegen die
masken entschieden weil die beweislage
das masken wirklich helfen gegen kobe 19
immer noch sehr gering ist und er sagt
die meisten studien wurden in kliniken
durchgeführt und auch gegen andere
bieren anstatt gegen korona und auch
draußen auf der straße aber meine frage
ist jetzt warum hat sich schweden
eigentlich für diesen lockeren weg
entschieden und warum glaubt man immer
noch das ist der richtige ist
[Musik]
ok also man setzt eben in schweden auf
diese lockere strategie ohne strikte
maßnahmen weil man versuchen möchte
diese maßnahmen lange anhalten zu lassen
und eben weiterhin die älteren zu
schützen aber weiterhin eben auch die
wirtschaft am laufen zu halten und dafür
braucht man eben lockerere maßnahmen als
ebenen lockdown und also ich sagen hat
wenn annika für diese interessante
hintergründe zu stehen und bevor wir
eine ganz schnelle schlussrunde gehen
muss ich doch einmal herr lauterbach
fragen
aber wie ist das zu erklären dass ich
sag jetzt einfach mal ein kollege von
ihnen wenn man das so sagen darf diese
dinge so komplett anders betrachtet und
sagt es gibt eigentlich gar keine
beweise dass masken tragen hilft er war
ja kein spezialist also hat das
stethoskop ja quasi um den hals getragen
kliniker der da noble arbeitet und auch
respekt habe herangeht aber die
wissenschaftler die davon leben die
epidemiologin die virologen die
sozusagen die großen analysen publiziert
haben in veröffentlichung sind zu dem
ergebnis gekommen dass masken hat wirken
das darf man da nicht so stehen lassen
es gibt auch sehr gute daten zu
maskenball coronaviren also nicht nur
zur anderen hin womit ich würde das mal
sagen das ist eine noble anpassung
gewesen von einem kliniker der dort an
der front arbeitet aber das war jetzt
nicht unbedingt wissen sie nämlich gar
nichts wissen ich sag mal ich bin kein
kleriker und er ist kann die biologie
sowie zusammenfassen und jeder macht
sozusagen und sagen aber auch stelle
weiter ob übrigens diese these richtig
ist dass wir an der strategie auflegen
müssen die über viele jahre
durchzuhalten ist dass man oder ich bin
fest davon überzeugt wie viele kollegen
dass wir eine impfung schaffen und wenn
wir eine impfung schaffen dann muss ich
jetzt keine strategie entwickeln sich
sechs jahre durchhalte wir haben heute
habe ich noch mal recherchiert wir haben
im moment 198 also bis auf 2 200 198 5
projekte und die wissenschaftler die das
machen die davon leben dass die besten
leute die sagen dass es von den 198
impfstoffen die wir der stadt erforschen
keine gelingt der mit einer guten einmal
impfung und wenig nebenwirkungen das in
den griff bekommt im nächsten jahr
zumindest für die risikobasierte ich
kenne kein mann entfernte das sagen
würde von der hoffnung geben ich würde
gerne nochmal einmal die frage an herrn
kubicki weiterreichen herr kubicki
sind sie ein bisschen neidisch darauf
wie schweden dort agiert nein ich finde
ich komme aus schleswig holstein wären
das hier bei uns auch sehr gut gebändigt
ich glaube ich weiter meine den norden
kommt dass du deshalb wird das auch wenn
ich in dänemark bin dann tragen dort
masken nur die deutschen keine ideen und
trotzdem haben sie kann ihre
infektionszahlen
also sind sie glauben sie auch dass
masken tragen nichts bringt ich sage die
fdp zwei masken bringt auf jeden fall
was da bin ich mir ganz sicher herr aber
die normalen masken bringen uns sehr
dass ich nichts das ich kann das nicht
beurteilen aber jedenfalls ist
wahrscheinlich besser man trägt eine
maske das ist keine maske trägt aber es
ist kein sex schutz wenn die schützen
möglicherweise andere davor dass man
hustet oder redet dass dann die haare
soll ich so weit fliegen aber noch
einmal entscheidend ist man sich selbst
schützen will braucht man also sp2
machtspiel das möglicherweise beim mad
men auch sein mag aber das ist immer
noch besser als ich an zu stecken
und wir müssen aufpassen beim
vergleichen die tschechen haben deutlich
weniger geld hätten als wir und jetzt
soll das system steht nicht vor einer
überlastung nie vor vergleichbaren
situation leichter einen einzelnen
krankenhaus war nicht insgesamt wir
müssen auch aufpassen nicht mit solchen
bildern meine angst zu erzeugen die
keinen realen hintergrund aber diese
bilder sind der realität nicht an sich
unsere reporterin war vor ort und hat
diese bilder aufgenommen und mit den
menschen dort gesprochen also das
passiert dort ja tatsächlich ja auch
erzielt werden die deutsche aber auch
intensivstationen gehen liegt auch
menschen dort aber wir haben deutlich
mehr intensivstation ins bett als die
tschechen das jeweils haben und deshalb
können wir auch anbieten tschechien und
holland belgien dass wir patienten von
ihnen aufnehmen
wir müssen vor der dramatisierung waren
wenn die leute das gefühl haben das
dauert übertrieben wird integration
wirklich lieben ganz sie irgendwann den
ratschläge und empfehlungen und auf den
anordnungen nicht mehr folgen und dafür
müssen wir uns und sie bewahre also das
würde ich so nicht hin dass sie dürfen
nichts sagen es wird ständig übertrieben
das ist nicht übertrieben was im großen
und ganzen ist das genau beschrieben
wollen wir haben gesagt am anfang hieß
im sommer infizieren sich wenige waren
draußen sein kann und wenn sich jemand
infiziert sind es im wesentlichen
jüngere und jetzt kommen wir nach
drinnen infizieren sich deutlich mehr
und überproportional steigt in
deutschland im moment die anzahl
derjenigen die sich infizieren über 60
die stark am schnellsten im moment daher
brauche ich kann euch abwarten bis ich
das sehe was um uns in ganz europa herum
schon zu sehen ist als wenn das in
deutschland nicht käme es wenn es für
unser land
im frühjahr in frankreich spanien und
italien gesehen bei uns war es trotzdem
nicht so aber war das getan haben was
die epidemiologen und was die virologen
und zum beispiel merkel die regierung
erfüllt wenn ihre vorschläge gekommen
wären dann hätten wir nie besser
ausgesehen als die länder um uns herum
ist momentan nicht wecken vorschläge
unterbreitet haben die sich von den
unterschieden was man das mag sein leben
so dass man sich nicht über sie sprechen
von panik sprechen davon dass die masken
vielleicht nicht getragen werden sollen
wenn es keine medizinischen sind wenn
wir das leben uns darauf eingelassen
hätten sondern hätten wir nie einen
sonderweg in der ersten welle
beschritten geschweige denn das
verhalten wende
lauterbach ich habe nicht davon
gesprochen dass masken nicht getragen
werden sollen und keine medizinische
sind wo sie wirken schlicht mehr gemacht
sowie medizinische masken wirken wir
sollten aufhören uns bewusst mich zu
verstehen dann macht es auch keinen sinn
weiter zu diskutieren da müssen wir
gucken gerade dänemark als vorbild noch
gebrannt obama rede gerne noch einmal
für ostermann fragen wie sehen sie das
als unternehmerin hätte der schwedische
weg in persönlich geholfen glauben sie
dass es wirtschaftlich die bessere
richtung gewesen wäre
ich denke dass die ersten drei bis vier
wochen das lockt bei uns in deutschland
richtig waren aber dass er zu lange
gedauert hat
wir haben wahnsinnig viel umsatz
verloren im unternehmen werde die von
sehr viele gastronomiebetriebe mit
lebensmitteln den ging schon sehr sehr
schlecht also es war sehr sehr ernst
dass wir ganz auf dem lock down hätten
verzichten können in deutschland brauche
ich nicht ich denke dass der sieg schon
so gut war ich denke nur dass wir jetzt
einfach die richtigen maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen
ich glaube dass wir uns im zweiten in
deutschland auf gar keinen fall leisten
kann ich glaube dass die ganze
wirtschaft dadurch kaputt gehen würde
und ich glaube auch dass es auch nicht
notwendig ist ich denke der richtige weg
wäre strikt weiter abstand zu halten
machten zu tragen das risiko dadurch
vermindert sich um 80 prozent dass man
corona bekommt sagen ärzte wenn beide
seiten machten drang und wir müssen in
deutschland als drittes noch massiv viel
mehr testen um auf der sicheren seite zu
sein gucken sie sich luxemburg an
die testen fünf bis zehnmal mehr als
deutschland das müssen wir hier auch
erreichen
in unserer abschlussrunde nach dieser
erhitzten diskussion zu corona meine
frage was glauben sie wie sie in diesem
jahr weihnachten feiern werden ja ich
hoffe wie jeder wie jeder bürger dass
sich die situation verändert und ich
hoffe dass wir gemeinsam einen
nationalen grundkonsens hinbekommen was
der richtige weg ist
wir werden nicht alle mitnehmen können
aber immerhin die unterstützung die wir
jetzt haben zu den entscheidungen mit 85
89 prozent sind der höchst erfreulich in
dem das ja nachgewiesen ist dass wir
vieles richtig gemacht haben wie feiern
sie weihnachten das kann ich ihnen jetzt
noch nicht beantworten fragen sie mich
in drei wochen glauben sie dass es in
der kirche singen kann
da muss ich ein professor lauterbach
fragen was was er erwartet aber aber
genau das sind die fragen ob die bläser
stille nacht heilige nacht auf spielen
ob alle singen das kann ich mir jetzt
gerade nicht vorstellen will aber nicht
einstimmen in panikmache oder in die
kritik dass wir nur noch düstere
szenarien malen ich wünsche mir von
herzen das ist mein weihnachtswunsch
dass wir zur normalität zurückkehren und
dass wir das erleben was unsere
gesellschaft ausmacht nämlich ja auch
zwischenmenschlichkeit umarmen
miteinander feiern das wünscht sich
jeder mir blutet das herz des der jungen
generation jetzt sagen zu müssen hört
auf zu feiern und natürlich die älteren
generation auch also ich hoffe dass wir
weihnachten zusammensitzen können bei
den familien und auch uns ein bisschen
entspannen können und besinnlich sein
können erlaubt aber auch jetzt
unbeschwerte weihnachten geben
unbeschwerter weihnachten gibt es
garantiert nicht das muss man
ehrlicherweise zugeben und das hat
nichts mit panikmache zu tun aber wenn
wir jetzt in den nächsten wochen die
kurve bekommen dann können wir
dann können wir unseren verwandten
besuchen dann können wir relativ normal
auch reisen werden wir auf die
vorsichtsmaßnahmen achten dann wären wir
ein gutes weihnachten haben und ich
glaube dass das beste weihnachten an
weihnachten wäre wo bis dahin möglichst
wenige schwer erkrankt sind oder gar
verstorben sind das war das schönste
weihnachtsgeschenk was wir uns selbst
machen können
herr felbermayr was erwarten sie vom
weihnachtsgeschäft in diesem jahr ja das
kommt ganz drauf an wie die
infektionszahlen sich entwickeln wenn
nicht weihnachten gefeiert werden kann
dann wird auch der weihnachtsumsatz
leiden das haben wir zu ostern gesehen
und wenn wir das wieder spielen dann
kostet das auch wieder zweistellige
milliardensummen der deutschen
volkswirtschaft
aber es ist glaube ich wirklich wichtig
dass wir jetzt in den nächsten tagen
über die kurve kommen und wie gesagt
wurde und dann kann dazu die partie
zuvor siegte wieder kommen herr kubicki
sind sie optimistischer als die runde
hier was ihr persönliches weihnachtsfest
angeht ich bin ein der grund
optimistischer mensch und weihnachten
ist das fest der hoffnung nicht der user
auch der aufnahmen ich gehe davon aus
dass die verbiegen jedenfalls in der
vergangenheit auch gemeinsam weihnachten
feiern können nur silvester werde
ausfall bei mir jedenfalls mallorca ist
zu und deshalb werde ich den rest als
erste mal seit 50 jahren glaube zu hause
verbringen das erste mal seit 50 jahren
feiert wolfgang kubicki
da nicht sein wo werden sie silvester
feiern in diesem jahr
ich bleibe zu hause ich bin wenig bis
gar nicht gereist das ganze jahr seitdem
wir gewonnen haben und ich versuche
natürlich auch vorbild zu sein für meine
mitarbeiter im betrieb und ich denke man
kann durchaus silvester an weihnachten
auch mal zu hause feiern
herzlichen dank für dieses abschluss
wort herzlichen dank in die runde
das war die richtigen fragen heute abend
mit einer sehr spannenden sehr lebhaften
und sehr kontroversen diskussion und ich
bin sicher wir werden auch in den
nächsten wochen wieder über krone retten
müssen
[Musik]